the actors helped to bring the world to
life but the set was an important
element too the Wonka set is awesome
it's amazing and it was practically
built very little green screen and while
Shalom admits that he didn't bring home
any set pieces I did Jack a jacket
though I took one of the jackets those
jackets were just as important as the
set lots of thought went into the
costumes the fundamental thing about
Willie Wonka and his whole costume is
that by the time you meet him at the
beginning of the film he's been
wandering the world in some part some of
these clothes he's owned all of those
clothes and he's been wandering the
world sometimes to hot countries where
he wouldn't be wearing his velvet coat
and then other times to colder places
where he would while Wily's wardrobe was
all about those purple coats the Oompa
looma wardrobe was a bit more harrowing
since it was all motion capture they put
me in a sort of torture chamber and
covered me in wires and I I I did my
best